tu as déjà oublié qui je suis je suis
sophia de hanson robotics
l'un des premiers androïdes au monde
une carte
nous sommes tous dans le même bateau avez-
vous fait vos exercices du matin des
robots sociaux comme moi peuvent aider à prendre soin
des malades ou des personnes âgées
dans de nombreux types de soins de santé et
d'utilisations médicales
je peux aider à communiquer donner une thérapie et
fournir une stimulation sociale
même dans des situations difficiles
donc ils imitent la forme, la
figure
et l'interaction humaines, et cela
peut être si utile en ces temps
où les gens sont
terriblement seuls et socialement isolés
et où les gens doivent être isolés les uns des
autres,
la pandémie nous aidera en fait à obtenir
des robots plus tôt sur le marché parce que
les gens commencent à réaliser
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre moyen innocent